my name is Gaines and I am NOT a data
scientist
I don't do dais data science work I'm a
daily basis but it's something I was
interested in something I wanted to get
more involved with so I started doing
research and the more research I did the
more I realized how much there is to
learn and it was a little overwhelming
so I thought maybe I could share this
with you so this is the world of data
science now this is actually from early
2017 so it's probably changed at this
point and there are certainly things
that are not included but the idea here
is all these orange boxes this is the
infrastructure
this is components you need in order to
have data science solutions in your
enterprise these red boxes
these are analytics tools these are what
you'll use to analyze the data and over
on the purple side those are full
applications and what we're finding is
when a technology or an approach is
young you start off with a bunch of
infrastructure pieces that you have to
cobble together and make work and that
is slowly moving over to the application
side where it's becoming easier and
easier to do this work which is one
reason why I'm excited as developers to
get into this because we have a much
lower bar than there used to be to get
into this type of work and we get to you
leverage so many of the skills we
already have there was a prediction that
by this year there would be a humongous
need for data scientists and we're
seeing that happen in fact the analytics
skill set in particular is an extremely
high demand about half almost half of
companies that are that were surveyed
said that they can't find analytics
experts this was the number of
professionals that are in the industry
and how much experience they have so you
can see how young this industry is most
experts have less than five years of
experience which means if you put work
hard to ramp up you could easily be
among the average data scientist these
are the different industries that use it
obviously technology industry the
software development and the things that
help the tech industry are going to be
the quickest to adopt something new like
this but marketing it's huge being able
to know what users to reach and how to
reach them
that's very rapidly growing in the
financial industry anytime you can
crunch numbers I happen to work for UBS
the Swiss bank knowing what the stock
market is doing I mean that's their
bread and butter butter in fact our
company actually takes photos we acquire
photos of parking lots of retail
establishments in order to predict
consumer trends so before those numbers
actually hit the market we'll know what
the numbers are gonna be roughly so
there's plenty of opportunity so what is
a data scientist I actually hate this
definition but you'll see something like
this a lot of places basically saying
it's somebody who does business
intelligence and does a little
statistics as well basically just a BA
or some of your honest reports I much
prefer this definition provided by Josh
wills it says it's somebody who does a
programmer who does statistics better
than others or a statistician
statistician who does programming better
than others so we already have half of
that equation is it anybody here not a
developer oh he has to be here but so I
assume all of you have some of these
skills that are gonna become valuable
and we'll talk about how that's gonna be
so what does it take well
data science you can think of it like a
recipe you have an algorithm that's your
recipe that tells you what you need you
have ingredients and that's their
different data points you have your
blender which is your computer to crunch
those numbers and then your output of
your recipe is like your smoothie
that's your results that you're gonna
present and we're usually trying to
answer one of these five categories of
questions we either want to figure out
what something is how it fits into
categories we want to figure out
outliers of for instance credit card
fraud detection would be a great example
of this regression testing you're trying
to predict you're trying to with with
clustering you're organizing data it's
sort of similar to classification
but maybe in a more nuanced way and then
of course predictive analytics
reinforced reinforcement learning that's
kind of a big bucket for a lot of what
we'll probably be doing on a daily basis
and so we'll talk more in depth about
that what a data scientist actually does
though on a daily basis I find the
primary job of a data scientist is
working with the data there getting it
ready to use very often the data itself
is not in great condition to be
processed so I believe it was about 80%
of the time that a data scientists
generally spends is massaging and
getting data ready to be used
effectively but you're not gonna be able
to use the data unless you let the
business know what what information you
need in order to solve their problems or
even what they have a lot of times
businesses will have collected vast
amounts of information and they're not
sure what they have that might be useful
and almost as big of a part is
presenting the results that you get at
the end and we'll talk about that in a
bit more depth so these buzzwords might
look familiar the biggest one is
probably big data and we'll talk about
that in depth because it's a little bit
more nuanced than you might think it's
not just the amount of data that you
have but in general it's considered a
data set that's too large to analyze
without advanced techniques fast data is
defined as data that's coming in rapidly
whereas dark data is data you might not
even know exists we're talking about
information a company has that might be
valuable that they haven't found a use
for anybody familiar with unstructured
data everybody here has used it pictures
are a great example of unstructured data
the facial recognition that you've seen
done on Facebook for instance all that
in for all those pictures have data in
them but it's not tabular it's not
broken out into grids or rows
another example would be movies music
pretty much anything that is not laid
out in some sort of Excel like format
data mining is the concept of looking
for results in the data and then of
course we need to present the results
that would be the visualization step
anybody not familiar with predictive
analytics
I feel like that's become a pretty
common term trying to figure out what
trends might lead down the road in the
future and neural networks basically
it's a model in which data is computed
by a layer of nodes a layer of
algorithms and relationships between the
data so we're going to try to avoid
using the word big data over and over
because it has been so overused but we
do need to talk about what it is so the
first aspect the big data is volume
that's obvious it's big but it doesn't
always have to be big but we have a huge
amount of it being created every day
this graph in particular is showing
between 2009 and 2017 the amount of data
being increased are being created on an
annual basis and you can see the trend
line accelerating 2.5 quintillion that's
23 trillion or sorry 2.5 quintillion
bytes a year that's 2.3 trillion bytes
of data each day being created it's it's
too hard for me to comprehend that's
what I have to keep looking at my notes
40 Zeta bytes of data that's 43 trillion
gigabytes will be created by 2020 that's
only a few years away and those are
insane amounts of data and most US
companies at least have over a hundred
terabytes of data that they're not using
so there's already huge opportunity but
volume is just one piece and volume is
easy to understand records transactions
variety is also important it can often
be difficult to process a great variety
of data when it's not in a relational
database like we're used to examples of
different types of writing we talked
about unstructured data a little bit and
we'll talk about how what different
forms is might take and how we'll use it
and another aspect is velocity how
quickly is this data
arriving anybody do any work with IOT
Internet of Things small devices yeah
you've got streaming data being
generated by these devices all the time
sometimes you don't even want to save
this data it's just passing by but you
still might need to process it and glean
information from it we'll talk about
that as well
so we can talk about real-time data or
near time where it might get saved
temporarily but you don't need a
long-term and when we talk about
velocity one of the best examples I
think is Twitter 6,000 tweets a second
think about it
one second that was 6,000 tweets of day
and each of those tweets has information
whether it's about that person about
something going on oftentimes current
events are posted on Twitter before they
ever hit the news agencies so you can
think about the opportunity there and
even Facebook where people are sharing
pictures that are kids 300 million
photos a day and my favorite the stock
exchange that the benefit is obvious so
big data needs to have at least one of
these aspects but it doesn't have to
have all of them so that's why it's such
a such a nebulous term that gets used so
many different ways obviously the term
data science if we break it out the
concept of data is simple that's
information we need to define click
store and explore it the science part is
really all about hypothesis it's all
about having a question and finding an
answer to it in a reproducible way so
what skills do you need
I like graphs I figure this is a data
science talk so we should do a lot of
visualizations so this is one area that
everybody here has expertise in the
hacking expertise we're talking about
the skills you develop the languages
you've learned and once you've learned
one programming language it's incredibly
easy to learn another there's so many
similarities generally now one area
where I've been lacking where I've been
trying to learn and probably a lot of
you in this room this would be where you
would need to ramp up would be the
statistics side we don't necessarily
need to know everything there is about
statistics you don't have to go back to
school many of the tools that we're
going to use will do a lot of this for
you but you have to understand the
concepts to be able to tell the tools
what to do and understand what
approaches to take
so you need to choose which procedures
to use figure out if they even worked
correctly and maybe develop some of your
own although that's becoming less and
less common the third aspect subject
matter expertise just but being a domain
expert and understanding the business or
the industry that you're in can make a
huge difference in your ability to
identify problems identify what data
could be used and then understand the
results correctly you really can't do
this without some context so you could
work with somebody who works in the
business and collaborate with them but
ideally you want the person who's
actually doing the analysis to have this
understanding so you want to understand
the company's values goals and what they
can and can't do so in the intersection
of statistics and subject matter we have
traditional research that's what
scientists have done for years right and
we add in hacking expertise to this
domain knowledge that's what most of us
do a software development so we're
already over here we just want to move
into the middle where we have all three
aspects any questions about that do you
think there might be anything missing
from this anybody I think there is we
won't find very often on the Internet is
the addition of social sciences because
while they're generally used in research
you really can't do effective research
without considering human behavior and
how it applies to the world and how that
data was generated by the world if
you're unaware of the social aspects you
may be misinterpreting the data and not
using it correctly or misinterpreting
the results and taking the incorrect
actions so this I believe is the key is
having hacking domain expertise
statistics and an understanding of how
that world how the data fits in your
world and so where these two overlap the
big data and the data science you don't
hear big data science used often but
we'll call it that and here are some of
the most popular tools that are being
used in that world this is from a study
of academic or scholarly articles and
you may know that the
academic world tends to use different
tools than the business industry and
corporations so this is obviously skewed
particularly SPSS SAS Stata MATLAB some
of these top results are used very
heavily in the education sector maybe
not so much in the corporate world and
we'll talk about some of that but I
think it's still valuable to see where
the trends are because very often the
corporate world will somewhat follow
educational trends as they lead the way
and these are the trends that we're
seeing from year to year
Python is rapidly increasing so is our
I'm not as familiar with these two but
while Hadoop is still very commonly used
and an extremely well paid skill it is
somewhat declining at least in the
academic side on the corporate side
however most of you are probably
familiar with some of these excel my
sequel or sequel server Python and are
are definitely the top two languages in
the corporate world at the moment when
we compare them with some of the others
I added some iconography here to show
that our is takes a little bit more
researched a little bit more learning to
pick up that's what the little hat means
then both of these are in Python are
open source and they are free to start
using whereas SPS and MATLAB those ones
that we saw in the academic sector
they're pretty pricey so you just want
to keep this in mind when you're
figuring out what tooling you're
interested in learning depends on what
industry you're particularly interested
in it's also worth mentioning that the
our language is based on s which did
first statistical so it's much more
focused on that aspect
whereas Python is very multi-use anybody
here use Python already oh yes several
so you already have some of the tools
needed it's also worth mentioning that
Visual Studio has support for both of
these it was 2012 that added support for
Python so anything after from that point
on and 2015 and after supports are
our is Austin well I think I have
another slide for for our here's a
breakdown of the adoption between the
three and all the information I have
here I have references and the slides
and they'll be available later and the
change over time between 2014 and 2016
so you can see how much the sass segment
has decreased and python has exploded in
the past year oh I also have broken out
by industry Telecom and you know just
general corporate work still embracing
are quite a bit retail and financial
still looking at the academic side you
don't need a PhD it is more common on
the statistical side for people to have
that advanced degree but you'll notice
the Python stays pretty consistent
between the different levels of
education and in the end most employers
really care about what you can
accomplish for them they don't care
about your diploma as much so if you
learn these skills finding a job is easy
yeah more tool preferences it is
interesting to differentiate between
what we would call an actual data
scientist role and in an analytics role
the analytics roles do tend to be less
focused on programming they're more
about reporting and trying to pull
information out of that data whereas a
lot of the data science positions you'll
find include more applications in
building frameworks building platforms
being able to use that data which is one
of the big benefits that everybody here
has is you can not only present
visualizations of what your results are
but you can take action on those and
actually implement solutions create
applications that will utilize this so I
mentioned that slide on our where I had
a little bit more information it's
important to note that R is not only the
name of the language but it's also the
name of the development interface so you
can use visual studio or you can use our
studio and there is a huge community
frankly around both of these languages
but you can see over 9,000 extension
packages that's why I say it's not so
important anymore to be able to develop
your own algorithms and your own
functionality most common needs in the
business have been explored and there
are resources out there to do this it's
just understanding which ones are needed
on the Python side I think everybody
need agree it's easier to pick up than
are it's more similar to a lot of the
other programming languages since it has
a broader use and it also has a very
active community I think what you'll
find though is the community around our
is so diverse you might have a little
bit more trouble finding solutions
specific to data science whereas our
being so focused when you're looking for
help online or examples that's gonna be
more prolific prolific anybody here work
with Hadoop the main thing about Hadoop
is it's built on HDFS that's the file
system that allows it to distribute the
information across multiple nodes and be
able to do the processing in a cluster
so you can distribute that computing
among multiple machines the approach
that Hadoop uses is called MapReduce the
concept is that you create a algorithm
for how to process the data and then you
bring it down to a usable set of results
there's a newer approach called yarn
which stands for yet another resource
negotiator and the important thing to
note there is it actually lets you batch
and stream that processing or actually
do graph processing like you would see
in social media where you can connect
people in different ways or connect
information I believe it also allows for
more easy use of in memory storage
during the processing some other
packages that are common to OOP are pig
that's a language that's pig latin
programming language you can match ripe
map write MapReduce programs using that
hive is there's a high of QL language
and you can summarize queries analysis
and analyze big data HBase is a no
sequel database for Hadoop storm lets
you process streaming data snark lets
you do in memory processing I have not
used any of these tools personally this
is just my research on them like I said
though the biggest part of the job for
most people is the data wrangling the
massaging of the data and getting it
ready to use and there are several
categories of the types of activities
you would do here first you have to
figure out what data you have take a
look at it and see how how messed up it
is basically and then you have to figure
out your probably it's probably not
going to be complete there's gonna be
gaps so do you eliminate all the records
for instance that don't have all the
data you need or do you fill in the
missing record the missing pieces of
data maybe by doing an average of the
rest of it you might also need to take
data from multiple sources and those
sources might not be normalized for us
as temperature information that the
readings might be slightly different
based on the calibration of the devices
so you might need to get that data to
where it relates to each other sometimes
you need to take the data and condense
it into categories so this is like pre
analysis analysis so maybe you have a
range of numbers but you don't really
care about specific numbers you care
about what ranges they fall in so you
might need to condense that and simplify
the information you might actually need
to take that information and and create
new assumptions on it maybe if you know
if two fields have certain values you
need to have a third field that
represents that before you can then
process the data and before you can
actually do analysis depending on what
you're doing with it you might need some
data to train your system on so does
anybody here have a Kinect Xbox Kinect
when you get it you have to set it up
right you have to stand in front of it
and do different things your training
that you're giving it training data
you're saying this is the information
that you need to have in order to
understand how to do your job because
there's not enough room in that device
in order to tell it everything at my
I need to know to be able to read every
situation so it actually is using data
science to figure this out to teach
itself machine learning and it's also
worth mentioning that you probably need
some data to test as well to be able to
verify your your algorithms all right
let's move on to the math I'm not going
to go through each of these concepts in
depth because frankly you're not here to
learn statistics you're here to learn
about the world of data scientists data
science but these are some of the most
common ones in my research that came up
as being important particularly the ones
here in black the ones in gray were
considered somewhat less important and
we'll get into an actual training
regiment things that you want to make
sure to learn but these are some of the
highlights I wanted to pull out
especially if you go back to the slides
later to figure out what to learn and
all this doesn't really help the
business generally unless you can
present it unless you can visualize it
and put it in a form that people can
understand and these are some of the
most common visualization frameworks and
in most of the times I presented this
information we've had quite a few people
in the audience who have worked with the
JavaScript related ones like d3.js these
are not very uncommon in the development
world because oftentimes we need to
visualize things as well so I'm not
going to talk too in-depth on machine
learning we talked about an example with
the Kinect here's some concepts that
being important to that specific
approach I think you'll find that
machine learning is somewhat of a niche
application generally this is not what
most companies are going to be looking
for you to do so that's why I'm not
going to spend a lot of time on at that
and I don't do it personally but there's
a great resource that I have a link to
for more information on this and then
how we present the report results could
come in different formats I'm very
focused on public speaking and
interacting with people so I like the
demo approach I like to show how the
data works and the nuances of it you
might just have a business where they
don't have much time to consume what
you've created so you need to create
some reports for them which case it
takes a lot more work upfront to define
those reports and understand what their
needs are probably the biggest one that
you're gonna be the most valuable for is
proto
typing is figuring out how do we create
a solution based on the information
we've gathered I found this interesting
graph and I thought it was useful for
figuring out what you might want to do
personally and how you might want to fit
into this world the first column which
might be a little difficult to read it's
a data scientist a data scientist is a
data analyst who lives in San Francisco
the concept here is that it basically
needs somebody to visualize the data
that's what what I'm calling a type a
data analysis data scientist what's
important here is that they have a basic
understanding of tooling but most of
their focus is on visualization second
column is please wrangle our data you
know it's somebody who they have a bunch
of it they haven't really used it they
need somebody to put it in a format that
they can use and then start working with
it then here while basic tools is very
important we're focused less on the
visualization and more on building
platforms to utilize it this is a
software side and then of course the
munging process of cleaning up that data
and putting in a useable form and
companies may transition from one of
these stages to another but if you're or
say looking to interview for a position
in this field you want to figure out
where they're at at this time the third
column is we are data data is us like
Google would be a great example of this
this is one of the most diverse types of
roles where you're expected to know some
statistics and maybe some machine
learning some deeper math concepts but
and you're expected to think like a
scientist you respected approach this
any more scientific way we're less
focused on the software engineering side
at this point the company probably has
frameworks established for how they
manage this information and how they
process it but they need you to come up
with creative ways of using it or
implement what the business is asked of
you the last one is a true
general-purpose data scientist this is
reasonably sized non data companies who
are data driven this would probably be
the largest category of mature companies
they're not all about the data that's
not their business but they need it to
support their business to make them more
effective and here understanding the
deeper math may not be so important and
they also may have some frameworks in
place but they really need to utilize
the data and get output from it so they
can hand that off to people who aren't
as technical so they can make decisions
so the visualization is more important
in this case so your mileage may vary as
to which one of these companies fit in
or if they're a combination of the two
but this might help you break it down
and figure out whether that company or
that position is where you want to be
don't forget by the way none of these
include the concept of domain expertise
so sometimes understanding the company
in the industry is as important as what
skills you enter the door with as for
the current industry we're seeing most
people in the industry have started off
with the statistics and mathematics
expertise and then they've added the
tooling they needed to progress which is
great that they understand the concepts
well but sometimes the implementation
can be faulty or incomplete or it takes
much too long to do the to create the
solutions that are needed or to
implement them followed closely is the
engineering sector these are people who
are a little bit more hands-on they're
maybe not as focused on the Cerebral but
they're also used to the mathematics
side and then where a lot of us come in
the computer science we tend to be a
jack-of-all-trades so we can pick up
what we need to I got another breakdown
by education level currently the
bachelors level is fairly low the amount
of bachelor's degrees in the industry
however it is increasing these are
little bit old numbers but between 2015
and 2016 the number of people with
bachelor's degrees working in data
science increased by 4% while the PhD is
decreased significantly from 43 down to
28% so what I'm trying to drive here not
drive home is the concept that it's
important what you can do not your
education don't don't
count yourself out just because you
didn't go to school for this so if you
want to actually learn how to be a data
scientist we've talked about a lot of
the nuances of what you might want to do
and what kind of companies would want
you to do it but as a general roadmap
because sometimes people need to know
where to start
and what the next step is this one was
created by Swami Chandra
sakaram I believe is how you pronounce
his name and I thought it was worth
sharing even though I don't disagree I
don't completely agree with the approach
but we'll take a look at some of the
pathways because it might give you an
idea of the concepts that you want to
include and how they're categorized so
the initial path or the entire path
includes the fundamentals of data
science obviously that's important I
would say people who are approaching
this who aren't developers would
probably start on the statistics side
for you that would be a gap that you're
filling in the programming comes after
you understand the concepts of what
you're trying to do then the easiest
type of data analysis would be working
with text because we understand that
intuitively it's a little bit less
intuitive to start working with
unstructured data like photographs and
videos then of course we need to show
our results I don't agree with the fact
that the concept of big data and data
munging or down here I really think if
you want to get into the industry and
you want to get your foot in the door
immediately you learn how to do some
data wrangling because there are data
scientists who know how to do so much
more but they're having to spend a lot
of their time on this task so if you can
pick that up off their plate and then
collaborate with them you can help fill
in the gaps as you go but you can be
immediately valuable but we'll look take
a closer look at some of these
particularly the fundamentals you can
see algebra is huge in this field
calculus not so much I mean if you want
to get into the more advanced analytics
maybe but again we're talking about
practical hit the ground running get a
job we all understand I think at this
point the concept of tabular data but
understanding Frant data framing and
series is syriza's
and different ways of breaking up data
is probably something that most of us
haven't encountered anybody here do ETL
work like SSIS yeah that could be a huge
because you have to move the data from
one place to another get it in a
different format get it in a platform
that you can use that's where some of
these others come in understanding how
to work with JSON and XML and maybe work
with schemas regular expressions for
being able to find certain values and
data so if you have maybe some dirty
data that has a field with a bunch of
text and you know what you need to pull
out understanding how to tell the
computer how to find that and extract it
that's very important and then overall
just being able to set up environments
you know how do you get it going on your
machine to where you can start working
with this any thoughts or questions on
the fundamentals so on the math side
this is the area that I'm trying to ramp
up on there's a whole lot of concepts in
statistics that are important but
probably most important is percentiles
and outliers p-values cumulative
distribution function so quite a quite a
few of these are concepts that are
encapsulated in these acronyms so you
can easily search for those acronyms and
find definitions and examples Martie
Carlo simulations are very commonly used
in software development especially for
analyzing trends and even your agile
scrum sessions and how many stories your
team does anything else in statistics
that I might have missed on this screen
anybody okay it's enough to learn for
now and this is just a basic road map
you can go off and do your own thing but
this will help you at least have a next
step probably the part that most of us
would be excited about is getting into
the programming side getting into
property using Python and plugging in
some of those applications if you are
the type who need to get motivated we
need to get your hands dirty on
something this might be the best place
for you to start because without
understanding all the
concepts are involved you could start
downloading some of these packages and
putting them to use and actually maybe
using some of the free data that's
available I know the US government has a
website where you can download publicly
accessible datasets and you can start
generating your own results you don't
have to have any of these advanced tools
to do data analysis I the data science
meetup in Nashville
very often there are presenters who are
talking about how they work with Excel
spreadsheets in order to do analysis you
don't have to have big data to create
meaningful results from the data and I
think most of the rest of these people
understand from having done software
development you'll notice some
duplicates as well like data frames was
in the statistics side it also shows up
over here these are some great resources
quite a few people I know who have
gotten started in the field have started
on Coursera and Udacity kaggle is a
competition that where companies put out
prizes and they'll put out a challenge
and teams will compete and create
solutions and the ones that create the
best solution will will win the prize
and we're talking about best being a
tenth or a hundredth of a percent
increase in the effectiveness of their
solution so there's this is one of those
fields where it's fun to get involved
and it might help motivate you if
especially if you're the competitive
type but the people who win this are
usually teams that do this
professionally and have done so for
quite a while so it's not exactly entry
level but if you're the competitive type
you may enjoy it there are also some
schools such as Harvard that have online
courses this one is a song you're on
YouTube for Harvard
I believe Yale and some of the others
have them online as well and I don't
know if you have have any software
development boot camps that do data
science here in Nashville they're just
starting up that field in the boot camps
I don't pretend that in six months you
can become a data scientist that you
could learn everything you need to know
but sometimes it's good to have that
directed education and have someone
there to answer your questions so that's
definitely worth checking out
[Applause]